ganz ganz toll wie man das machen kann
einer so kurzen zeit organisiert muss
sagen danke allen soldaten die hier
mithelfen
danke bisher wir wissen es ist keine
militärische aufgabe die er derzeit für
unser land leistet eine logistische
organisatorische und personelle
herausforderung der großartigen meister
auf dem ball der offiziere habe ich
zusammen musizieren können mit jungen
soldatinnen und soldaten
die sind fantastisch ich weiß was sie
können und deswegen weiß ich auch was
sie jetzt können auch in dieser
krisenzeit wenn sie uns testen helfen
wenn sie überall da sind vor probleme
gibt die wahl selber soldat war zwar
beim militär
die war sie das obst wurst wurden job
heute durch das man diesen angriff
geringe beute wieder auf die bühne
möchte wieder kasse spülen
ich weiß ihr seid im mega einsatz auch
ich war mal beim bundesheer bin sogar
als gefreiter abgerüstet aber er war
sicher schlechter als ihr denn ihr macht
das großartig danke für einen einsatz
ihr seid carola weiter danke danke danke